ah freemium the business model that has
dominated the 21st century whether
you're trying to consume media trade
stocks or stream music you can do it all
for free you just need an internet
connection this was one of the biggest
revolutions brought on by the internet
it made information education and
building businesses more accessible than
ever before but more recently there
seems to be a trend against free
services YouTube has managed to Garner
80 million paid subscribers Apple music
has managed to Garner 78 million paid
subscribers and even protonmail a
premium email client with paid tiers has
managed to Garner 70 million users each
and every one of these Services has a
free alternative instead of YouTube
premium you can just watch YouTube with
ads instead of Apple music you can just
stream Spotify for free and instead of
protonmail well you can use virtually
any other email client but despite this
more and more people are choosing to pay
for for these traditionally free
services in fact it's almost become sort
of a status symbol oh you still watch
ads on YouTube what a peasant this
mentality is especially prominent
amongst the younger generation of high
schoolers and young adults but it goes
beyond just superficial looks the
reality is that there is no such thing
as a free service if you're not paying
with cash you're paying with attention
time and or privacy and as people become
more aware of this reality the more
willing they are reclaim their attention
time and privacy using cash companies
are even starting to use this as a pitch
as to why users should pay for a service
protonmail for example proudly claims
privacy isn't free here is why that's a
good thing but while I agree that
reclaiming privacy is definitely a good
thing for customers it's not exactly a
great thing for businesses and I'm not
talking about Google or Facebook this is
great for them if they can just directly
monetize their billions of users they no
longer have to be the bag guy that's
collecting and selling data the
companies that this is bad for are the
ones that are trying to advertise on
these platforms suddenly everyone who is
well off or even middle class are
impossible to reach making it
exponentially harder to craft successful
ad campaigns this could lead to a pretty
scary future for YouTube as advertisers
become a lot more aggressive so join me
as we take a look at why free services
are falling out of favor and what this
means for the freemium economy
[Music]
the bottom line is that free services
are never worth it while it's great that
these companies are able to offer their
amazing services for free if you have
the means to pay for an ad-free version
or a private version or whatever you
should always take it the reason is that
free services are terrible at monetizing
users yes platforms like Google and
Facebook do make a crap ton of money but
that's just because they have a
mind-bending level of scale on an
individual basis these platforms make it
next to nothing and it's no wonder why
there's simply so much friction when it
comes to monetizing a free user base
take YouTube for example let's say that
you watch about one hour of YouTube per
day nowadays you usually get an ad once
every three minutes and each ad is about
10 seconds so you're watching about 100
minutes worth of ads every month let me
phrase that in a different way by not
getting YouTube premium for 12 per month
you're essentially selling your time for
7.20 cents per hour or basically minimum
wage in the US also that's if you do it
stupidly the smarter choice would
obviously be to go for the family plan
and split it with your friends and
family the family plan costs 23 dollars
per month and allows for up to six
members so each member is only paying
about four dollars per month so by not
getting YouTube premium you're actually
selling your time for 2.40 cents per
hour and that's if you just watched one
hour of YouTube per day if you watch two
hours or are selling it for a dollar
twenty if you watch three hours you're
selling it for just 80 cents and if
you're a YouTube addict like myself and
watch five or six hours you're selling
it for just 40 to 50 cents not to
mention you'd also be sitting through 10
hours of ads every month YouTube was an
easy example but this is the case with
all free services it's impossible for it
to be any other way because of the
physics of the situation for a normal
service to work only two parties have to
be happy
business and the user for a premium
service to work three parties have to be
happy the business the user and the
monetizer this is made worse by the fact
that most users don't want anything to
do with the monetizer I mean who wants
to watch ads this makes it especially
difficult for the monetizer to make the
transaction worth their time and by
extension it also makes it difficult for
the business and the user to have it be
worth their time either back in the day
users didn't consider this inefficiency
too seriously as far as they were
concerned they were getting Media or
email or news or whatever else
completely for free but nowadays if you
don't know how these platforms make
money you're definitely living under a
rock and people are simply coming to The
Logical conclusion that giving up so
much time data and privacy just to save
the five or ten dollars of the service
would have otherwise caused is straight
up stupid now again it's great that you
can access such great services for free
but if you can't afford it you should
stay far far away from such deals as
they're always ripoff for everyone
involved
[Music]
so that's kind of The Logical argument
as to why people are ditching free
services but this shift is much deeper
than a simple time versus money
relationship the reality is that people
simply don't trust free services back in
the 2000s the average internet user
might have thought oh it's just a
website how much could it possibly cost
to run it that must be why it's free but
no one in their right mind thinks that
today everyone knows that internet
companies are some of the most
profitable and wealthiest companies in
the world so how exactly are they making
this money and more importantly where
does that leave the average user of
course the average user would be giving
up time data and privacy but I don't
even think that's what a noise users the
most I think what annoys users the most
is the fact that they no longer have a
voice because they're no longer the
customer they're the product being sold
while the monetizer is the real customer
this is what leads to the disconnect
between users and plug platforms that's
so common nowadays oh how could YouTube
remove the dislike button why does
YouTube censor great content just
because it's a little edgy why did
Robinhood hold GameStop do these
companies even listen to what their
customers want well the answer is yes
these companies are very much aware of
what their customers want and they give
them just that advertisers want family
friendly content that they can get
behind as such that's what YouTube
pushes to the top at first users will
complain about it but eventually they'll
get over it something that they don't
get over though is the loss of trust
users start classifying these businesses
as sellouts that don't even care about
their customers but the reality is that
the only way that these businesses could
have done it differently is if their
users were also their customers so
naturally people have started to flock
over to Services where they are the
customer where they feel valued this has
already started to become more of a
status thing and you can thank Apple for
that apple is one of the only big tech
companies whose users are actually their
customers and they're very much leaning
into this just take a look at all of
this marketing about privacy privacy
that's iPhone privacy matters privacy
that's Apple what happens on your iPhone
stays on your iPhone all of this is
actually very similar to that protonmail
slogan that we were talking about at the
beginning of the video and all of this
enforces the idea that an ad free
experience and data privacy come at a
premium cost which you can get at Apple
and let me just say people are eating
this up the iPhone has barely changed
over the past five years but the same
cannot be said about the iPhone's market
share iPhone's market share has gone up
substantially from about a third of the
US market to over half of the US market
and as Apple continues to grow their
dominance and spread their message you
can bet that people will only become
more inclined to pay to be the customer
thank you
so why are people ditching free services
well people have simply come to the
realization that free services aren't
exactly free and the people are very
much fed up with free services and their
ulterior motives personally I think that
this is a great thing for companies and
users companies make more money directly
from the consumer and the consumers get
a better experience while paying for
exactly what they're consuming it makes
perfect sense but it's not great for
everyone and it's especially bad for
advertisers you see advertisers have
already been screwed by the new age of
media on YouTube We're literally
complaining about three minutes of ads
for every hour of content on TV it used
to be like 12 minutes of ads for every
hour of content and it still is it's
just that no one really watches TV
anymore at least no one from the younger
Generations so advertisers were already
fighting for four times Less ad space
and ad-free offerings are just making
this exponentially worse I mean who
tends to pay for pain premium on YouTube
or Hulu or Netflix or really any
platform well people who are well off
and are able to spend a little more on
entertainment and who is the most likely
to convert from ads well people who are
well off and are able to spend a little
more on entertainment
so these ad-free offerings are literally
removing the most valuable audiences
from an already limited marketing poll
this leaves advertisers with only one
option Target the content this of course
means more companies doing sponsorships
and paying way more we'll also see more
brand placement more affiliate marketing
more giveaways more brand deals and all
of the usual stuff but is that where
it'll end I'm sure you've noticed one
common thread amongst all of these
they're all skippable now there are
advantages to skippable ads only people
who are really interested in their
product will watch that and the
advertisers can get away with paying
less but with that being said some
advertisers will always be looking for a
way to push unskippable ads how would
they be able to do this though well
would YouTube ever push out a feature
that allows creators to show ads even to
premium members you're probably thinking
that this would be Blasphemous why the
hell would you pay YouTube a premium
price if you still have to watch much
forced ads well I don't think YouTube
wouldn't necessarily make money from
these ads I don't even think it would
necessarily be a feature that YouTube
ads on their own rather it could very
well be a feature that creators ask for
due to how much brands are willing to
pay they would probably justify it by
saying that they can make even better
content if viewers just watched one
unskippable ad at the beginning of the
video and then it'll become 2 and 3 and
4. pretty soon it'll become just like
mainstream tv YouTube will make money
from the premium subscription just like
DirecTV or Dish Network and the creators
will make money from ads and
infomercials just like TV channels and
their shows so is the trend towards
premium subscriptions all that great
well it really comes down to your
personal preference would you rather see
higher quality content with more ads or
lower quality content with less ads
comment that down below also speaking of
ads YouTube recently blocked Adblock
this might have been one of their worst
decisions yet check got this video to
learn more but until then I'm hori and
I'll see you guys on the next one